[Music]
my name is Shashank Joshi I'm a
specialist leader in cloud engineering
practice of Deloitte Consulting and I'm
Stephen Elliot I'm a product manager on
a cloud billing alright so here is a
quick agenda
we'll start off with the introduction
what is cloud cost management why it is
important and then we'll look at a
real-life Enterprise example where we
helped build their cloud cost management
solution then Stephen will talk about
what tools and services Google cloud
provides for cost management then we'll
see couple of demos to walk you through
what you hear in the session today and
we'll wrap up with Q&A and just a
reminder you can go to your door yep ask
a question or vote on a question that
you like all right so let's get started
what is cloud cost management
fundamentally it's about controlling
monitoring controlling allocating and
optimizing your cost so cloud promises
accelerated innovation and reduced cost
but in reality that cost savings are not
always realized and another big impact a
big change from your traditional optics
model is in the traditional environment
you have your budgeting cycle than once
a year or once a quarter right but in a
OPEX environment you have to do it on an
ongoing basis so you need a solution
that can do that for you so just look at
why it is important the cloud cost
management and you decided to attend
this session that means you understand
why it's important but still let's go
through some of the analyst research on
this one so when asked about what is
your greatest barrier for cloud adoption
the second greatest barrier was cited as
the cloud cost management just only
after cloud secure the data security
which can be which is the number one
greatest barrier and within cloud cost
management when asked what is your top
pane so 61% of people said that the
predictability of your cloud
is the is the greatest pain point for
them and what happens if you don't have
effective Clawd cost management solution
so 69% would over spend up to 25% of
their cloud budget so this is a pretty
significant number and if you don't have
a plan for a cloud cost management you
would always spend more than 70% of your
budget so these are really big numbers
so it's really important to have a cost
management plan and have a cost
management solution in place so now that
we know that why cloud costs management
is important you would want to start
what your solution first has to answer
so what are the questions you want you
would want to answer using your cloud
cost management solution so the first
important fundamental question is how
much does your app cost and depending on
what level you are looking at it can be
one app a bunch of apps or all of apps
in your organization so you would want
to know how much it takes for you to
deliver value to your business through
your apps second fundamental question is
what are your cost trends your industry
you can be in a seasonal variation
industry or regular industry but you
should know what area trends overall and
also for individual apps and finally
what are your cost Ivor's so what is
driving your cost what are your top five
spend areas how would you do it down
into that so that's another important
question even though these are
fundamental questions and Google cloud
provides a lot of solutions out of the
box that can answer these questions for
you and in a matter of minutes that
Stephen will showcase later on but these
are not all the questions that you need
to answer these are the fundamental
questions but based on your organization
you may have much more many more
questions so let's look at one example
where we helped build a billing data
analysis solution for a fortune finite
retailer so just to give a quick
background on on this customer so a
couple of years ago they started on a
really big transformation journey using
GCP we help
build a business case for them and it
was a very exhaustive business case in
terms of what initiatives milestones
going down all the way to the
applications and very early on in the
journey we realized the importance of
cloud cost management solution and as we
were getting ready building the
foundation getting ready for the bigger
transformation we also started building
the solution required for cloud billing
data analysis and reporting so as part
of the cloud cost management team we are
responsible for oversight analysis
reporting for all aspects of cloud cost
management so we needed a system which
can meet all these challenges so the
first set of challenges where
organizational challenges and I'm sure
all bigger organizations would really
face this so every organization will
have some kind of a structure for
example they'll have lines of businesses
vice-presidents departments applications
and stuff like that so how will you
overlay all of this data your
organization structure onto your GCP
billing because you may have to have
showcase all of that back using that
structure and second option was how will
you combine multiple data sources so GCP
billing is not the only source of cost
in your overall system so there are so
many other systems like licensing other
third-party tools other Colo and other
cloud products as well so how will you
combine all those multiple data sources
so your solution has to be robust enough
to combine all of these sources and
drive meaningful insights from that and
finally in terms of organization there
are different levels of stakeholders so
how will you break down the reporting or
analysis based on different stakeholders
and how will you control access right
you wouldn't want application lineup is
just one to look at it by no business to
data like that and in in terms of data
challenges working with billing export
schema is really important so sooner
your team is very familiar with your
billing export schema and overall
bigquery it's really important and how
would you distribute shared services
right so there can be shared
like networking monitoring so how will I
distribute that cost and some of the
credits that come they come at our
organization level
how will you distribute those credits
back to the respective folks and finally
every large organization would have some
kind of a data analysis reporting
solution in terms of cost already
existing so whether you will choose to
extend that solution you know you know
for GCP or you will want to build a
brand new one so that's another question
you need to answer so with this
challenge is in mind this is how we came
up with this is the overview of the
architecture that we build so if you see
on the on the left hand side there are a
bunch of data sources of course DCP
billing export that was a major data
source and as a best practice we have to
enable you should enable TCP export on
day one and then there are other GCP
data for example we actually had a lot
of other requirement in in terms of
getting more data from DCP for example
how many instances are running into
environment so any other platform
related data so we had custom scripts to
capture all of that data and I use no
dump it into bigquery and then
organizational data write all of your
org structure your VP's
your department's your budgets all of
that organizational data has to be
brought in as well for meaningful
insights and we'll see that in the demo
later on you can have third-party tools
data and you can have other clouds or
Colo provided it as well you would want
one single solution to do to visualize
all of that right instead of going to
multiple different solutions for storage
and analysis we use bigquery initially
we started off with the on-prem solution
but later on realized related to
challenges related to cost and
functionality we decided to get
everything into Google Cloud so using
bigquery as our storage and analysis
solution and we'll see some of the
example in our demo how we use that
actually and we had a bunch of
automation and scheduling because
the org data that you see here or the
platform data that is coming all of that
data was automated so there were scripts
running all the time scheduled and there
were third-party or the organizational
data coming in to CSV files and whenever
there was a change in the file the
automation pipeline would update the
table and finally we used a bunch of
bigquery views to join all of these
different data sources and for
visualization where we use tableau
because that was the tool of choice so
before I go to the next one I just want
to highlight a couple of key highlights
of the solution so for cost
organizations we use labels so we
decided a labeling strategy very early
on and as a best practice you should
spend time on define deciding the
labeling strategy and not just for
today's my or near future or maybe
slightly longer than that because it's
really hard to change once you decide on
labeling strategy that was one important
part and because of that labeling
strategy we were able to drill down not
just by the VP but going down to the
department going down to the application
going down to the environment so there
was visibility going across all the way
down second interesting part we did was
we used billing export data merge with
so many other data sources and we will
see how that is useful later on in the
demo so don't be afraid to really merge
different data sources with your billing
to get more insights and finally we
created a lot of custom fields as well
and we will see one example of that if
you have seen your bigquery export for
every service you have multiple SKUs and
for compute engine for example there are
thousands of scoob's so if you wanted to
jump from service to SKU that's a much
bigger jump so we came up with the field
called
SKU categories so we wanted to
categorize some of the SKUs into
something more higher-level and more
meaningful because not everybody would
want to go to the SKU cask the actual
SKUs later on and we will see how that
helps later on as well
and in terms of impact so the major
impact was the visibility from the
get-go so we could track the spend on an
overall business case level and the
leadership could see now how they are
doing and make adjustments so this was a
great tool to the overall leadership to
look at it and see how we how well we
are performing we serve in the business
case and not just that because the
reports were available all the way down
to the app owners and developers it
really helped make that mindset change
from capex to OPEX
as the granular level data was available
they could see impact of their actions
if they'd design an application in
certain way they could see a positive or
negative impact on the cost immediately
in near-real terms so that really helped
create the capex to OPEX mindset and in
terms of analysis because everybody
could see what their budget is and how
their spend is going on a daily monthly
weekly basis
it created a culture of accountability
across the organization and as everybody
could see what are their top areas of
spend they could manage what are they
talking as of spend do something about
it and kind of control that and overall
it helped improve the forecasting and
predictability because everybody was
able to see how much their application
cost yesterday today and based on the
load variations what it will cost
tomorrow and finally in in terms of
insights it helped identify a lot of
optimization opportunities and couple of
examples I can give when we realize the
compute cost was much higher we dig
deeper into that we saw in one instance
the licensing cost was much higher so we
decided to look at why is it higher so
is it is there some way that we can
address that maybe using B bio-oil like
we can reduce the cost other examples
where we identified a lot of storage
related cost and compute and then that's
where the custom scripts came it came in
handy because we wrote custom scripts
that could go through all of your
projects and find out orphaned discs the
discs which are not attached to any
instance so you are paying for storage
for those instances don't those discs
and not using them so that is our that
was another opportunity to delete or
take a snapshot and do something about
that and finally other opportunities in
terms of making this as part of your
culture the cost optimization is
becoming part of your culture and to do
that we had regular governance meetings
with your with our lines of businesses
on trends and recommendations so rather
than making like it of once once a
quarter or like a long term activity we
made it a habit or governance to do it
like bi-weekly basis and one of the
interesting anecdote I remember from one
of such meetings was when we were
helping out predicting one how to
predict the cost for one of the yellow
bees we realized for for a peak because
it's a retail customer there was like
peaks and troughs for their usage and we
were trying to estimate how much it will
cost when it goes on a peak so obviously
we had a unit cost on a traditional
basis but during a peak your overall
on-demand usage goes up right so you
have certain commitments for a lower
cost but you cannot make commitments for
a short period of peak so during the
peak your on demand instance usage goes
up so and that actually pushes your unit
price for compute up higher as well so
when predicting for a peak you not just
have to predict for the increased
capacity you order in you know predict
use the increase unit cost as well keep
in mind that as well so that inside was
really useful for some of the yellow B's
to make accurate predictions about how
the peak would look like and finally
before closing out about this use case
what are some of the key takeaways that
you can take back to your billing
systems so the first one is billing
analysis and reporting is not
one-and-done kind of solution right and
we actually developed this solution in a
very agile iterative fashion so don't
try to collect all your requirements for
all your dashboards very early in that
in the cycle you should start building
reports and start improving on that like
no bi-weekly basis so if you do it in a
trader fashion that's that's the best
way to do it
the second one is decide your data
pipeline and reporting tack early on we
had to make corrections I just meant in
the Midway but always you should now do
some due diligence to decide your data
pipeline stack early on and identifying
optimization opportunities should not be
a rarely occurring thing it should be
happening much more regularly that way
you can control your cost so with that
I'll hand it over to Steven to talk
about the clock cost management tools on
GCP all right thank you sharing this is
actually kind of funny cuz I never
thought I would get to present billing
in an IMAX theater so an exciting day
cuz I get to check that off my drilling
bucket list of life goals so we talked
to lots of customers big and small and
there's several key themes and shawshank
kind of alluded to these that we want to
address with our cost management tools
and these are what's on the screen right
now so visibility you know the basic
ability to view your costs in a way
that's meaningful to you
accountability so once you know you know
the cost of some meaningful logical
grouping say the fully loaded cost of
the application I just shipped last week
now who do I hold accountable for the
cost you know the cost of that
application who do I reward for having
delivered it efficiently and and who do
I have a meeting with who did not
deliver it efficiently but more
seriously you know what what what is the
corrective action if you see cost
staring to run away and then control now
this is a big one because there's both
the proactive you know explicit control
and the tools that you use to control
costs and then they're just the sense of
control and that ones is hard to put a
finger on but often a bunch of different
tools can give you the sense and the
feeling of being in control that's often
just as important for you and your
leadership you know if you're a CIO or
VP or you're an engineering manager it's
that sense of control that lets you be
confident that you're doing the right
thing and then intelligence so you
expect to get insights about your costs
suggestions about where you can optimize
what you're spending and get those from
the platform
get that easily from the data so that
those are the kind of four priorities we
have on billing and I'm going to talk
through the tools and then show you the
tools and then demo the tools so
there'll be three different ways
depending what kind of learner you are
so we have built in reports that come
straight out the box they're ready to
slice and dice in the billing console if
you want to get access to the detailed
data we export all the detailed data
like shaq mentioned to bigquery which is
a really powerful tool to get really
fast
query results on large amounts of data
so you won't be limited by bigquery if
you want to join it against you know
rich operational data we have
recommendations so various products have
different recommendations for example
compute engine has VM right sizing
recommendations to show you where you
might want to have a larger instance or
a a smaller instance depending on how
you're actually using the cores in
memory in your VMs and then customizable
dashboards so this would be in in the
case of a Google Product data studio
plugged into bigquery or if you have
your own solution you're using tableau
or looker or some other solution plug
that into bigquery as well on the
accountability and control side of the
house again this is all about giving you
the tools you need to feel that you are
in control and can see costs and don't
get surprised by costs as your teams are
iterating and kind of operating
autonomously so one is just billing
access control being able to set the
rights to view costs for the right users
by default billing account
administrators and project owners and
users get to see the costs of what
they're doing then we have budget alerts
and automated actions so you can set
notification thresholds on your spending
in a project or in a billing account so
that you receive an email if spending
goes over threshold or you get a pub/sub
message sent to some programmatic
function that responds to it and takes
corrective action and then there's the
resource hire hierarchy so this is just
how you want to organize your resources
your usage into projects have multiple
projects under folder have all of that
under your domain and then set standard
policies kind of at the right level of
the hierarchy and then finally here
there's quota and so one way to think
about quota
is the proactive control of usage
setting in advance what someone's
allowed to use and then budgets an
alerts that's notification so that's a
lagging indicator to respond to things
after they've exceeded a certain
threshold so this this graph makes me
laugh just because I I kind of
stubbornly oversimplify it
despite the most vigorous feedback from
my engineers so on the Left there's
usage metering from GCP products so if
you're using compute engine or storage
it's emitting usage to what I've called
here the pricing engine which doesn't
exist this is a chimera it's not a real
thing but it's a really complex system
that takes the usage figures out the
right pricing and credits and discounts
to apply to it and packages that to send
to downstream systems so one is
important to us that's payments that's
how we make money but for this talk
the yellow items and the red items are
what are important so we send the cost
and the usage downstream to all the cost
management tools billing reports export
and dashboards and budgets and alerts so
if you run into Jonathan thorn D craft
or anyone else and you talk to him just
don't mention the word pricing engine
talk about something else but this is
basically what it does there's a great
talk about resource management actually
later today I'll give you the talk
number by Greg and max teammates but at
a high level the items that you should
think about are how do you set policies
and users in your domain and
organization and then how do you pay for
your projects with a billing account
usually most customers have one billing
account so this shouldn't require too
much thought the payment profile just
something to be aware of and make sure
you have the right user set on those so
they receive the invoices and they're
able to pay for the invoice and then
projects folders and labels which
shawshank referred to and I mentioned
which are the ways to organize your
resources and be able to identify costs
of the same group so this is this is a
part where I'm just going to show you
what all these things are before I demo
them so reports look like this they're
they work out of the box you don't just
set anything up and any time you log in
you can see a report that lets you slice
and dice the costs for easy visibility
and then billing x4
if you go to bigquery and you have been
an export enabled you can just look at
the table where all the costs are going
and either run the queries in line here
or in the query via command line or VN
API or plug it into Data studio or
tableau and then maybe have an
experience we don't even need to write
the query for example in data studio you
can just kind of do a
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
configuration of the charts that pulls
directly from billing export and then
gives you something like this and we
actually have a template and shawshank
will show that in the demo or you can
just copy the template plug in your
export table and then get it to start
populating real data from your own
account and budgets and alerts this is
per per billing account or project and
then you can easily set multiple alert
thresholds based on actual spending
level or a forecasted spending amount
and that's a new release we came up with
that just to just a couple weeks ago so
that's a that's a nice one that I'll
talk about and then just the mental
model for how programmatic budget alerts
and and programmatic consumption of
those alerts work you can think of you
know the manual method is we sent an
email to the billing administrator and
say your spending is approaching your
threshold you might want to do something
about it or just you know just a
heads-up programmatically if we sent the
same message v2a pub/sub topic you could
have something like a cloud function in
just the pub/sub topic a message anytime
it arrives and then decide what to do
with it so for example one solution
would be to just send a slack message to
a slack group and say hey just FYI the
budget the spending is trending up or if
it's a sandbox project and you're
completely comfortable blowing it away
you could have a more draconian
programmatic response that says ok you
spent more than four five hundred
dollars that was your test account your
test accounts been shut down and this is
just kind of a small pitch to cloud
function but when I say it's easy to
write the programmatic consumption of
the pub/sub message cloud functions are
really short snippets of of code in
common languages so here we have a very
short function that does a quick budget
check and then does kind of pushes the
big red button and says disable billing
because we exceeded the budget so for
budgets in quota again keep in mind
budgets are
you're lagging indicator it's when the
spending has happened which means the
usage happened before that and quotas
you're proactive control and the quota
policies can be set for different
products you can you need to decide
whether or not a user should be able to
run a lot of big query or have run a lot
of instances and on budgets that is kind
of a catch-all so if the project spends
a certain level that cut captures all
the all the products in that project if
a billing account spends a certain level
that just captures all of the spending
and activity in the billing accounts so
quotas are also more targeted to the
actual products being used so another
important aspect to cost management and
many of you may be familiar with this
but if if you get into a good rhythm of
building the dashboards as shawshank
mentioned and and having teams
accountable for their cost and regularly
checking these it actually does
something interesting and it makes the
culture more kind of operationally in
tune with what's going on we've had
customers like here van dusted Albert's
say that once they've put up their cost
management dashboards they've identified
things they probably wouldn't have
identified otherwise so they have a
great talk where they're talking about
run awake storage spending so usually
storage spending that runs away slowly
is something that's kind of hard to
catch and then you might notice that
over months but you would have to
actually look at the long term trend and
have someone you know proactively look
at that but if you just have a dashboard
that says you're today spending and you
see a trend that's going up it's hard to
miss just because humans are so great at
identifying the visual trend and usually
cost is a great proxy for operations so
if there's a deviation in cost or
there's a trend in cost that doesn't
look right but just looks like it
deviated from the past pattern usually
that correlates to something interesting
or wrong in operations and it's it's
just a really nice proxy that everyone
understands whether it's the you know
the VP or the engineers that something
it has started to change from the status
quo
so for the demo Welsh washing sets that
up what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
kind of an end to end and show you kind
of how we recommend using the different
tools starting from kind of the simplest
use case to the more involved custom use
case that shank was talking about with
his engagement with the retail customer
so right now we're in the cloud console
this is the home page for a project and
there's two ways to get to your cost
data the first one is just the billing
card and here the the project spent two
thirty five dollars so far
that's all the way over there two and
thirty five dollars so far this month
and I can either go to billing reports
here but before I do that I just want to
show you you can also go to the billing
page and console by just coming to the
billing menu and then going to reports
down here but for now I'm going to go to
a via the card so I'll see you know
first question of my task is where this
that where's that $235 coming from these
are under control does it does it look
like it's a reasonable amount of spen so
if I click on view detailed charges and
view detailed charges great okay so now
I'm here this is amazing zoom out but
it's this is the most high-power
projector and yet somehow alright so
once you're in reports what we were
mentioning is you get kind of an
at-a-glance view of where your spending
has come from and where it's going this
a right size or should i zoom in a bit
more fine so you immediately get a sense
of what your overall spending is on the
left to date 235 we actually spun this
up for the demo so that's a big increase
over the previous ten days and then we
have a projection of what we think we're
gonna spend by the end of the of the
month so $250 by the end of the month
now that's like that's curious you would
think that if we spent $235 in the first
ten days of the month the projections
should be something more like 700 you
know six hundred seven hundred dollars
by the end of the month but the way
we're doing the projection is we're
looking at I'll just do a custom date
range we're looking at the historical
go spend Trent here so if I went back to
January and said you know what what's
kind of the trend in spending well
usually here usually means the last time
we use this project we did a big burst
and then shut it down and so that's why
the projects and things that we're not
going to exceed 250 so that's just this
project and what I can see is that the
spending is coming from some skews so n1
predefined instant score that's a
compute engine core part of the VM and
then there it's must be running Windows
because there's a Windows Server license
on it datacenter Edition and then some
RAM for those instances but that might
be too granular so let's see you know
group by product and it's all compute
engine and there's some stack driver
logging at zero cost so the next thing I
might want to do is just say well I'm
the billing account administrator let's
look at so if I want to see all of those
spending in the billing account I could
just select all projects so right now it
shows me with just one of the 18 in this
billing account because I'd come to it
from the project homepage so show me
everything and let me know you know how
my entire team is doing spending wise so
now that forecast has changed because of
spending across the billing account
across all the projects is different so
I might group by project just to see you
know what are the high spending projects
and so far the highest spending project
this month is Phil's amazing application
and the one we had come from was the
feel-good app dev and again where's this
where's this trend line coming from into
a custom range maybe take it back to
January so you can see as we're ramping
up for next we've been doing some more
tests it's a more kind of demo testing
spinning up some VMs so Sheng can show
you the demo later in this session and
then the forecast is actually saying
well typically on this day of the month
you've been spending this much and
you've been increasing month over month
so we think you'll have kind of a big
spike and spend around here and then
he'll go down again so the nice thing
about the quick slice-and-dice ability
reports is now you can start to answer
some real real questions really quickly
even operational ones so one thing I
might want to know
is I see that I'm the fill good app dev
suddenly started having usage it didn't
have usage before you know kind of
before mid-march I might want to focus
just on that one and say well where's
that spending coming from and and you
know what why is it getting started so
if I focus on that it looks like there
was a bunch of spending that happened
around March 12th March 13th and again I
can kind of drill back in we saw what
that was that it was a compute engine
and then when we looked at it even more
we saw that it was an n1 predefined
instance core
so once we've kind of identified
something interesting then you know this
only takes the matter of minutes you can
go to stackdriver and just seen the logs
well who's responsible what's
responsible for the spending we know
generally speaking it's a predefined
instance core so we've got a stack
driver just go here driver logging
I'm still in the same project so Phil
get app dev and I'm interested in these
VM instances who's running these VM
instances where they come from let's
look at the activity logs so we got
compute activity log and then here we
had a date range of interest so it was
March let's say March 13th can be the
start date and then maybe look at the
whole day they're sent nd
and so now I'm looking at the logs and I
can kind of immediately see a start to
see some instance insertions so you know
here it looks like we've been having
some activity and some of that activity
so here there's some config changes by
shawshank and if I looked further I'd
see some instances getting stopped by
Shawshank and then some instances
getting started right so now I've got a
sense of the accountability it's it's my
it's my partner that's great
it could be me because I am logged in as
him but I'm gonna pretend that it is so
the next thing I might want to do is
just set a budget on that so actually
I'll show you how to get there
so I'd say well you know I trust him to
an extent but I don't I wouldn't trust
him with my entire demo so go to billing
and then go to budgets and say well
let's let some notifications on the
billing account so the project was fill
good app dev go to the link to billing
account for that and then set a budget
for it so when I create a budget and
this is pretty fast so budget um don't
let Shawshank end more budget and let's
see but billing reports demo that's the
project and you know the budget amount
might be something like a thousand
dollars I want us for more than a
thousand I'm comfortable with a thousand
for the demo for the month but not not
that much more I mean then now just the
auto suggested thresholds just notify me
at fifty percent ninety percent a
hundred percent another interesting
thing that we launched is you could say
I would also like to be notified when I
am projected oops it has to be unique so
I'm just gonna delete that and use a lot
when I'm projected or forecasted to
exceed the budget and so you don't have
to wait until you exceed a threshold
just say when when we forecast you're
gonna see the budget even if it's only
the tenth of the month or the fifteen
the month we should alert on that and
then finally you could either get send
that via email or connect it to a pub
subtopic if you want to respond to it
programmatically and because you can
have multiple budgets you can set one
this just sends an email and then set an
identical one then sets
that sends a pub/sub pub/sub alert so I
think the topic is in this project you
just have to select a pub sub topic to
send the message to so alert email save
that and then you have a budget that
helps me stay in control of my demo
spending and then again the cloud
function itself could be very simple so
if you're going into cloud spending if
you if you go into cloud functions I'll
just cheat and go over to the tabs
you'll get a list of all the functions
in your project and this one is actually
one that's very simple it responds to
any messages sent to the pub sub topic
alert email and in this case it's a
function that just kind of Ford's it
it's not it's not truly an email and it
just Ford's it to slack and that you
know if you're using a standard standard
language like nodejs
just include the slack library and then
and then post a message to it so this is
a fake token but post a message to the
slack channel and they'll just post the
contents of your pepsiman and that's
that is your functional you don't have
to do anything else and when you hit
deploy that function will start
responding to the budget alerts so it's
a really powerful tool and you can learn
more about it in a deep dive talk that
my colleague Phil Coletti is going to
give so now that I've kind of gone
through how I control shawshank spending
I'll let him talk through billing export
and data to your dashboards sure thanks
Steven I really hope you didn't catch my
pet project but you did so the tools are
pretty good so so I'm going to talk
about how will you overlay some of the
arc data that I spoke about in in the
Enterprise example with your billing
data and how we can use that so just to
set an example let's say you have
multiple adobe's in your environment
three lines of businesses multiple VP's
if you see these names familiar these
are the docker container name generator
so these are the VP's and each of the
VP's would have one or more applications
and each applications would have
you know environments and each
environment will be in a specific
project and to overlay this structure
with your billing usage you have to have
a labeling strategy so I'm using labels
such as environment so whether it's a
dev test prod what like lob it is lob
one two three what app it is whether
it's feel-good all is well and you get
the idea right we are using some
interesting names here so this is this
is good but how will you really
implement that into into bigquery is
where you can create for example
building export is where your export is
and you can create another data set for
our data so we have a table for lob to
VP mapping let me show you that so it
can be your lob mapping map back to your
VP name and we will see how we how will
you join that with your bring export and
let's go to the next level of details so
you may have some budgets for your
individual VP's so you can create
another table with that map's your VP
with your month and budget and all of
these details can be stored in a CSV
file and you can create automation
pipeline so whenever there is a and we
can check this CSV files back into your
source code repository and whenever
there is a change let's say a new VP
joins our VP leaves or a budget change
on a month and one you update the CSV
file and that automatically updates your
bigquery table so that's about your art
data to overlay with your billing data
now let's look at some of the other data
I mentioned about SKU categories as a
custom field that we used so that's
where we created a table that gets your
service your all your SKUs and inserts a
category called SKU category just for
simplicity there and let me show you how
effective is that so here I am using
four for example for compute engine just
if you see the licensing itself so as I
mentioned there are like thousands of
services SKUs and within computing just
for licensing there are hundreds of SKUs
so if you see there are in this case
there are 16 different
scuse in my usage itself for licensing
and for reporting I may just want to see
all Club all of them together as
licensing right so that's that's what
I'm doing here and then let's look at
the other important thing I mentioned
was about the platform data so in this
case I actually created a Python script
using Google API so what it does is it
goes through all of your projects gets
all of your instance data and kind of
dumps it into bigquery table and you can
schedule this script to run like every
two hours or every day based on what you
want to use and this is just one example
the API is so enormous and useful you
can write as many custom scripts so this
particular script gets the details of
the project it's running in what
instance a name what region and so on
it's running in and how many cores and
RAM does the instance have and we will
see how that data is used and because we
are using project labels to map to line
a business now you can map all of these
instances back to your VP so now we have
created the structure so there is a
billing table and there are a bunch of
different tables for your alt data for
the other data now let's see how you can
join all of this to make some meaningful
dashboards so for that we create a bunch
of views let's look at those views so
the first view that you see here is
billing daily view so here what we are
joining here is I hope the text is
visible so we are joining the main
billing table with the SKU categories
and with the LOB mapping so what you get
as a result is you can map your billing
usage by your VP and by the SKU category
so you are merging these joining these
three tables the other view is the
billing monthly budget view so in this
view you're joining your billing table
with your alow B's as well as your
monthly budget so that's why that's how
you're joining these two tables and
finally the instance data and
so in this particular view you're
joining the instance data with the VP
table and the LOB table right so this is
just an example to set it up how you can
join different tables together with your
billing export so you created the tables
additional tables of course you had a
billing export then you need to create a
bunch of views on how do you join these
different tables and then finally you
create the dashboards and as Steven
mentioned it's really easy to do it's
data studio dashboards if you just
search on GCP billing data studio sample
on on google you'll see that you'll see
Stephens photo here I think it's a
really nice talk from last year so must
see a see youtube video so what you do
is you just click on this one this link
and it takes you to to a page here and
there are details given on how to how
data studio works but in more
interestingly there is start working
with your sample billing report so you
just click on this link that takes you
to a sample dashboard so that gives you
out-of-the-box
many dashboards write your analysis by
projects analysis by resources spending
trends App Engine bigquery all of these
reports are available to you and it's so
easy to use in your environment you just
click on make a copy and give your data
source you are billing export here so in
my case is billing export table I just
click on copy report and all those
dashboards you see those are available
for my environment like out-of-the-box
so this is how easier it is to really do
this so this is can give this can give
you out-of-the-box reports but how to
make some of the custom reports that we
saw so many tables so many views how do
you consume that so let's go to the next
cost management custom reports and a
shout-out to David Wright who helped
creating some of these reports and views
so the first one because you saw me the
first view that we had was combining the
VP and lob table with our billing export
and because of that let me increase the
font size here so because of that you
could see the spending by the VP's so
you can see the amazing Aria but I
spending most of the money for you the
other insight that you see here is there
are some unassigned costs as well so
these are the projects which you have
not labeled and it's really important as
organization to for you to see what are
my costs are not label not allocated
right so it's really important this we
clearly visible from here now let's look
at we had budgets for everybody right so
let's look at how they are doing visibly
the budgets that they have so this is
the view where we combine the budgets
table with the billing table so you can
see for example relax Richie's or VP he
is below our budget so he can continue
to stay relaxed let's look at somebody
else so mistrusting Torvalds he's
actually exceeding his budget so we'll
have to have a discussion with him and
why is that so you can see what they are
doing visa we daily budget and monthly
as well you see daily spend monthly
spend visibly their budgets coming back
to the SKU categories because these are
categories these are much higher level
abstraction so you see licensing fees
here as the second biggest cost driver
that gives you a really good view of
where your cost is going so instance CV
CPU is definitely number one but
licensing is number two so you should
you would want to drill down and Stephen
saw when he caught me with my pet
project that there is a bunch of Windows
machines windows licensing read had
licenses as well so you may want to look
at that as cost optimization and finally
let's look at some of the custom GCP
script so we had the custom DCP script
getting all the instance data and how
that is useful combining with your other
org data
so now you can see by each VP how many
different types of instances they are
running right so why it is useful you
you may be running a lot of your
developers may be running a lot of
custom instances right so that is an
optimization opportunity whether you
would go to the standard instance and
save some cost instance this persone
this may be important from availability
perspective if you're over subscribing
one zone over another for example in
this case amazing re-baptize kind of it
his team is you know prioritizing one
zone or others and these dashboards of
course in Rampur zone these details are
really useful for you to make informed
decision on how many commitments you
want to buy on each of the zones in each
of the regions and finally weather
instant status you can do it like
running terminated right how many
instances which are shut down and just
left like that you would want to kill
those or to eat those this is just
example it's a few examples but you can
make as many custom reports and combine
that together can and can we switch back
to the slides right so just to wrap up
we mentioned some best practices these
slides will be available online later
but these are worth kind of reiterating
which is on day one you've seen the
value of having billing export enabled
so you should enable that when you have
a billing account and that way that
historical data is always available to
you and in my dem I showed you how
reports are just a very easy tool to use
to quickly find date range and a product
or SKU of interest and then use that as
your jumping-off point whether it's
stackdriver or the detailed logs and
that exploration if you know the tools
can take you no matter minutes to figure
out what's what's driving something
finally it's really worth putting in
some effort to think of how you organize
your work and how you want to manage
your cost to build custom dashboards off
of that from the detailed billing data
so you can spread those dashboards data
studio lets you share them easily so you
can share those dashboards with your
company and then related to that is to
just developing your cost management
strategy and thinking about how you're
organizing the resources and the
projects how you want to label across
cutting span
across different projects and different
resource types so that you can easily
see fully loaded application costs or
fully loaded team costs and then finally
if you do all this right just really
work at building that culture of cost
ownership making sure people actually
use the cost dashboards and are
iteratively improving it as shawshank
was mentioning earlier so that they both
get the cost accountability side of it
but also the engineering excellence that
can come out of being really strong cost
owners
[Music]